Tag zusammen - Jack Pop hier. Wir sind wieder in Jena. Da waren wir vor ein paar Wochen schon unterwegs und
haben Superhelden einem Realitäts-Check unterzogen. Und Ihr habt uns neue
Vorschläge gemacht und einen davon haben
uns ausgesucht. Heute geht es nämlich um Kirby.
Aber auch weil wir Retro-Games
einfach lieben oder Henry? Wir lieben sie.
Henry ist hier an der Hochschule Physik-Dozent und der wird uns heute zwei
skills von Kirby erklären und ob die im
echten Leben auch so funktionieren würden.
Skill Nummer eins, das ist
natürlich Kirbys krasse Saugkraft.
Auf jeden Fall. Saug-Effekte funktionieren
grundsätzlich über Druckdifferenzen wie
zum Beispiel ein Staubsauger. Das heißt
es gibt Orte größeren Drucks, Orte niedrigen Drucks.
Und der hohe Druck
drückt die Luft in Richtung des niedrigen Drucks.
Und um uns rum ist eigentlich
die ganze Zeit ein ziemlich großer, krasser Druck.
Und dazu habe ich mal was
vorbereitet.
Und zwar sehen wir hier als Blau die
Erde und das Gelbe ist die Erdatmosphäre.
Und über uns sind viele Kilometer Luft,
die mit ihrem Gewicht auf uns drauf drücken.
Und auf einen Quadratmeter
Erdoberfläche drückt die ganze Zeit eine
Masse von Luft von etwa 10.000 Kilogramm.
Das ist ziemlich viel.
Und die richtige Einheit des Drucks ist eigentlich Pascal.
Und wenn man diese 10.000 Kilogramm pro Quadratmeter in Pascal umrechnet,
ergibt das einen Druck von insgesamt 101.300 Pascal, der permanent auf uns drauf drückt.
Das heißt also Henry, wenn Kirby jetzt was einsaugen will, dann muss er in sich drin
einen geringeren Druck erzeugen als draußen Luftdruck ist. Ganz genau.
Und das macht er so, indem er einfach
sein Volumen vergrößert.
So funktioniert auch unsere Lunge. Das Zwerchfell vergrößert unser Lungenvolumen, der Druck
sinkt ab und jetzt ist draußen der Luftdruck größer und drückt die Luft quasi in unsere Lunge rein.
Und wir können einfach mal ausrechnen wieviel Druckdifferenz in Kirby herrscht,
wenn er sozusagen einatmet. Und dazu benutzt man einfach eine einfache Formel.
Wir nehmen an, dass Kirbys Temperatur im Inneren konstant bleibt.
Das bedeutet, wenn sich das Volumen vergrößert, verringert sich der Druck genau um denselben Betrag.
Und wenn wir annehmen, dass um Kirby rum genauso viel Druck ist wie wie bei uns,
dann macht das eine Druckdifferenz von 50.000 Pascal. Das klingt viel - und jetzt muss man
noch rauskriegen, ob das reicht. Ganz genau. Also die Druckdifferenz ergibt sich aus
der Kraft, die auf den Körper wirkt multipliziert mit seiner Querschnittsfläche.
Und die Kraft wiederum, die ergibt sich aus Masse des Gegners mal die Beschleunigung.
Und die Beschleunigungen, die habe ich wieder nachgemessen. Auf den Gegner wirkt eine
Beschleunigung von 6,5 Meter pro Sekunde zum Quadrat.
Das ist ungefähr zwei Drittel der Erdbeschleunigung auf der Erde.
Und die Masse, das ist das, was der Gegner wiegt. Genau. Wie kriegen wir das raus?
Das Internet sagt, dass Kirby 20 cm groß ist und 280 Gramm wiegt. Wie ein Stück Butter.
Und es gibt große und kleine Gegner.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, ein Kilogramm nehmen wir als Masse für den Gegner an.
Und als Querschnittsfläche, die sind ungefähr immer gleich groß wie Kirby, deswegen nehme ich
einfach dieselbe Querschnittsfläche wie
von Kirby. Und wenn wir das einsetzen und
ausrechnen, kommt da raus, dass das
insgesamt 207 Pascal sind, die nötig sind
um so ein Gegner einzusaugen.
207 Pascal, das ist ja viel viel viel weniger als die 50.000, die in Kirby drin sind. Das heißt, das würde funktionieren.
Genau! Theoretisch würde das funktionieren. Hast du mal ein paar Vergleichswerte, um das einzuordnen?
Bei einem tiefen Atemzug, wenn wir tief einatmen, da schafft die Lunge eine Druckdifferenz von ungefähr 3000 Pascal.
Und so ein handelsüblicher Staubsauger,
der schafft zu 20.000 Pascal. Aber.
Diese Annahme, die wir hier gemacht haben mit der konstanten Beschleunigung, die ist ziemlich grob.
Das ist nur ein theoretischer Wert.
Und zwar wird die Druckdifferenz nämlich
sinken, wenn immer mehr Luft in Kirby
reinkommt. Das bedeutet, der hält diese
Beschleunigung nicht die ganze Zeit
aufrecht, sondern die wird immer weniger.
Sonst könnten wir auch beim Einatmen
irgendwelche Kilogramm schweren
Gegenstände einfach ansaugen. Okay. Schade. Funktioniert also nur in der Theorie.
Das heißt, Kirby müsste so eine Art Turbine in sich drin haben - wie beim Staubsauger, damit
das konstant funktioniert. Klappt aber
nicht, das heißt, Henry, wir brauchen ein workaround.
Genau. Es gibt nämlich noch eine andere Möglichkeit, wie Kirby einen
geringeren Druck in sich zu erzeugen
könnte. Und zwar, indem er sich innerlich abkühlt.
Safety first - ich habe die Schutzbrille
auf und Henry hat die Skibrille auf.
Ja, ich trage nämlich im Labor auch
manchmal den Skianzug. Sehr nerdy auf
jeden Fall. Henry, erklär uns das Experiment. Wir erhitzen hier drin ein bisschen Wasser.
Daraus wird Wasserdampf. Das ist ein Gas. Und dann nehmen wir diesen heißen
Kolben, stecken denn hier rein, das Gas
kühlt sich ab, nimmt weniger Raum ein,
dann sinkt der Druck und der äußere
Luftdruck drückt die Flüssigkeit in den
Kolben rein. Und das wäre quasi der Saugeffekt, den Kirby nutzen könnte.
Und deswegen haben wir euch diese
Flüssigkeit, das ist ganz normales Wasser,
so schön Kirbyfarben eingefärbt.
Henry, let´s do it. legen wir los.
Und was wir hier schön sehen, ist dass das Gas, was vorher den ganzen Kolben eingenommen
hat das passt jetzt hier oben dieses
kleine Stück rein.
Skill Nummer zwei ist, das Kirby zu schweben scheint, wenn er aufgeblasen ist und nach unten fällt.
Und wir haben hier mal einen Kirby-Ballon
mitgebracht. Henry, warum ist das so?
Weil wenn der Ballon aufgeblasen ist, wenn Kirby viel Luft in sich drin hat, dann
ist er ja eigentlich schwerer. Müsste er
da nicht schneller nach unten fallen?
Macht er nicht, weil eigentlich fallen
alle Körper gleich schnell.
Theoretisch - aber es ist ja nicht so, dass
heißt, es gibt Effekte, die dem
entgegenwirken. Genau.
wir haben hier zwei Effekte, die hier eine
Rolle spielen. Das erste ist der
Luftwiderstand. Je größer ein Körper ist,
desto mehr Fläche er hat, desto
größer ist der Widerstand, den ihm die
Luft entgegenbringt. Und das sieht man
beispielsweise an Fallschirmspringern.
Dass heißt, ein doppelt so großer Kirby fällt aufgrund seiner größeren Fläche langsamer.
Zweiter Effekt ist: der Auftrieb.
Das heißt, jeder Körper, der sich in einem
Fluid, einer Flüssigkeit, in einem Gas -
beispielsweise der Ballon in Luft -
befindet, der erfährt eine Kraft, die ihn
eigentlich nach oben drückt.
Kennt jeder wenn er in der Badewanne sitzt oder im Schwimmbad, da fühlt man sich leichter.
Ja, das ist das, was Archimedes
rausgefunden hat, als er in die Badewanne
gestiegen ist und das Wasser
übergeschwappt ist. Das ist deswegen so,
weil an der Ober- und Unterseite von
Kirby unterschiedlich starke Drücke sind.
Okay, das heißt hier oben ist weniger
Luftdruck als hier unten und deswegen
gibt es quasi den Auftrieb, eine Kraft
die dem entgegenwirkt.
Deswegen fällt Kirby langsamer. Und das
können wir euch auch noch mal
demonstrieren. Wir haben nämlich einen
Riesen-Kirby mitgebracht. Henry, du
bekommst bei den kleinen und ich habe
mir noch mal den großen Kirby für euch
mitgebracht. Den größten Luftballon,
dem wir finden konnten.
Die lassen wir zeitgleich fallen. Henry, ich steig mal hier nach oben.
Du gibst du mir den hoch, und dann zeigen wir euch, dass das wirklich funktioniert.
Und wir starten jetzt hier auf derselben
Höhe. Henry: bei 3 - 2 - 1 - 0!
Spitzenmäßig!
Fassen wir also zusammen: Kirby könnte,
wenn er die Druckdifferenz aufrecht erhält,
seine Gegner einsaugen durch
Temperaturunterschiede oder so eine
Turbine in sich drin  - das würde
funktionieren. Als Riesen-Ball würde er
außerdem wirklich sehr sanft zur Erde
sinken. Das haben wir hier im Experiment bewiesen.
Wenn ihr noch eigene Ideen habt für Superhelden, dann schreibt sie in die Kommentare bitte.
Henry und ich wir freuen uns auf neuen Input. Auf jeden Fall!
Ansonsten sehen wir uns erst mal nächste Woche. Bis dahin. Tschau!